presidential candidates in Turkey are
making their final pitches to voters in
the most closely fought election in the
country's recent history the opposition
contenderoglu received a potential boost
against President erdogan after a
candidate dropped out of the race pulls
open on Sunday was part of our special
coverage into the lead-up to the
elections let's bring in Sami zaydon
he's joining us from Istanbul so just
two days until the elections how's it
all shaping up Sammy
two days indeed that in two days before
an election that could change the
direction of this country not just
domestically but globally too and in
these two days it's now the day before
campaigning ends and well you might
think things start to wind down at this
point but if anything it seems to be
intensifying and we've got
correspondence right across turkey we'll
be going to them later on get a peek at
what's going on at different campaign
rallies around the country and there's
also been some interesting developments
when it comes to International Politics
as well in turkey's election we've had a
warning from the main opposition
candidate for the presidency Kamal
College he's warning Russia against
interference in domestic affairs
interference in turkey's election we'll
be getting more on that in a moment with
our correspondent in Ankara let's first
of all kick things off with silencio
although she's live in Istanbul where
she's been keeping an eye on what's
going on the build up for campaign
rallies for the ruling art party in this
stumble and synonym we understand or
there are expectations that President
will be making some big announcements at
some of those rallies today right
well Sami yes the politicians the
candidates are actually finalizing their
rallies today and tomorrow and as of 6
pm tomorrow Saturday evening uh the the
Restriction will totally be in place no
one will be able to do any propaganda or
any campaigning right now there are
smaller campaigns rather than big
rallies that we saw last weekend during
this week however we are waiting for
president erdogan to come to some
special districts in Istanbul normally
he always spends Fridays at Istanbul and
the weekend as well and tomorrow again
he's going to be in Istanbul especially
in Biola District where he started his
political career career as a local
politician before becoming a mayor of
Istanbul and there are very strong
suggestions that tomorrow evening when
he speaks on National TVs he is expected
to speak around 10 pm local
um he's expected to give some
information about the new economic plan
of the government you know because of
the high inflation the depreciating
Turkish lira and the rising costs of
living the hyperinflation everybody were
started to blame the government
especially the president who has
interfered in the central bank's
monetary policies and many blame
president zardon for this High inflation
as he has been against the Orthodox
rules of fiscal policies
many suggest that the new economic plan
that erdogan is going to give some clues
about tomorrow evening are prepared by
his former strong economic team former
deputy prime minister Lucifer elvan who
ran who was a finance minister and also
by mehmed shimsheik Mohammed shimsek was
also a minister he was also Deputy Prime
Minister and he is one of the
finance
Administration people of the Rolling Gap
party who have been appreciated by the
global market season his his reputation
goes far beyond that's why we expect
erdogan is going to deliver something
because we are seeing that as you said
the campaigning is intensifying not only
through the ruling act party and its
presidential candidate erdogan but also
through the opposition as well and many
are saving last time bullets as the
Turkish people are undecisive until they
go to the ballot boxes this is what
history showed us Turkish people decide
at the very last minute so there's
always a time to influence the
electorates preference
all right thanks so much soon because
all the reporting there for us from
Istanbul Let's uh also take a moment to
take in another very important segment
of the Turkish population that's of
course the ethnic Kurds they've long
played a prominent role when it comes to
elections and tipping the balance with
this election being so close they can
only play an even more important role
let's go over now to Zana she's live for
us from gazi Intel we can talk more
about this and zaina we know one of the
main Kurdish opposition parties they're
headype they've been endorsing the
opposition this time round are Kurds
listening to that call
well yes we were in the southeast of the
country this is the heartland of
turkey's Kurdish population the majority
of the people there want change that's
what they're talking about they're
talking about a new beginning a new era
of relations with the Turkish State uh
during the last election the main
Kurdish political force the hdp fielded
their own presidential candidate this
time around they have thrown their
weight behind the opposition they're
hoping that they don't want to split the
opposition vote and they're hoping this
is the only way to unseat the president
or Dugan who have they have really
fallen out with in recent years most of
the people we've spoken to we've spoken
to in the arbucker they say that you
know we've been discriminated against we
have been sidelined we've even been
targeted and really the relationship
between the hdp and the ruling act party
deteriorated as the peace process
gradually collapsed in 2015. so the hdp
calling out it's a supporters to vote
for the opposition and what we noticed
on the ground is that the people are
going to heed that call
[Music]
stories from the past
oral culture passed down from one
generation to the next
here in turkey's Kurdish Heartland
there's a long history of struggle that
many say hasn't ended
my life is getting harder day to day as
a Kurdish I can't speak my language on
the streets they are looking at us as a
terrorist
many Kurds are hoping the upcoming
presidential election will bring a
change in leadership they accuse
president rajib Talib erdogan of
implementing undemocratic policies the
main Kurdish political force has thrown
its weight behind the candidate fielded
by a six-party opposition Alliance we
need to get rid of
is the person who seems to
replace him
then
we will have a new ball game we will
have a new process we have a new
historical era but it's an unlikely
Coalition in terms of ideology the
parties that have joined forces have
little in common apart from their goal
to unseat erdogan
uh
the relationship between the opposition
Nation Alliance and HTP is not based on
trust and Kurdish Waters know this but
there is no alternative
the ACT party came to power chp-led
governments suppress their rights in the
last election the Party's candidate
received just less than 10 percent of
the vote in Kurdish majority areas
but now CHP leader kilichdar oglo is
saying the right things promising to
resolve Kurdish issues in Parliament and
release political prisoners but not
everyone is convinced
they're using us Kurds all the parties
are trying to benefit from us for
political bargaining
for now many Kurds are focusing on what
their vote can do possibly tip the
balance and what they say is a crucial
ballot and Usher in a new chapter in the
country's history
of an important voice in Sunday's
election at least 10 percent of the vote
Sammy
all right thanks so much damage
and of course a lot of rallies going
across the country a lot of activity
going on between political parties let's
go to the seat of political power in
this country in Ankara also Sardar joins
us live from there so first of all
before we get into the aspects of the
horse trading going on behind the scenes
I want to start with that Warning by
Kamal college.olu the main opposition
candidate for the presidency a warning
against Russia tell us more about that
why did he warn Russia
well it is quite interesting now that
you know after uh huge pressure from the
main opposition parties CHP on muharam
India to withdraw from the presidential
race then we have seen that in the last
couple of days there have been some of
the montages some of the tapes
disturbing images videos being
circulated on social media and then
yesterday Muhammad just came in front of
the cameras and has said that announced
that he's withdrawing from the
presidential race because if the
opposition loses on May 15 he doesn't
want to be the scapegoat he doesn't want
to be blamed just hours after that you
have seen that the the presidential
candidate of the opposition Ally Kemal
consider although has tweeted and said
dear Russian friends we know that you
are behind this montages Behind These
conspiracies videos that were circulated
on social media and if you want to
remain as friend get your hands off the
Turkish state so he simply said Russians
that you are interfering into the
Turkish electoral system or the Turkish
election and I've been talking to some
of the sources from CHP whether their
leader is just making a a a kind of
situational assessment or whether he has
some concrete evidences they told me
that their presidential candidate has
some concrete evidence that Russians are
interfering into the electoral system of
the turkey and also interfering in their
election campaigns because Kamal
cholesterol is promising bad relations
with Europe with the West with USA and
also with NATO and so that's why he's
sending out a message to the West that
in case if he becomes president of this
country then the relations with Russia
are not going to remain as before so
that is now the situation here is
absolutely publicly born in Russia if
you want to remain as France get your
hands off the Turkish State it's quite
interesting that now these Turkish
elections are becoming internationalized
and we have seen that there was a huge
debate in the USA particularly the
Russian interference in their electoral
system now this is happening in Turkey
as well however as I said they said they
have concrete evidences but they haven't
been released to the media yet
all right
it's really interesting also because it
also gives us a little bit of insight as
to perhaps the foreign policy directions
of the opposition Camp should should
they come to power in these crucial
elections let's talk a little bit
into another
in presidential candidate who pulled out
of India yesterday and kalistarolu the
main opposition candidate for the
presidency what are they working on is
some kind of endorsement coming together
here
well yesterday there has been some of
the claims being mostly circulated on
social media that CHP has sent an
invitation to Muharram inject to attend
their rally which is going to be held
today in Ankara however just after that
we have seen that Muhammad has released
a statement saying that he hasn't
received such an invitation but that
doesn't mean that it's not going to
happen so we'll see within hours CHP is
going to hold a rally in Ankara in the
capital and if Muharram India appears
there come up there then it's going to
be a real surprise and of course a huge
endorsement to the opposition so we know
that wasn't CHP MP and in 2018 he was
the presidential candidate of CHP and
all of the opposition Ally so when he
decided to run for president and also
formed Homeland party he was criticized
hugely significantly because CHP and the
opposition was accusing him of the wide
in the base the wise in the wars and now
that he's pulled out the the
presidential race and he if he appears
in the rally then definitely CHP is
going to regard this as those who are
supporting him now are coming back home
and that's going to give a huge
advantage to the opposition
all right good stuff there from The
Sword started off thanks so much yeah a
clearly an exciting time a turbulent
time a dynamic time call it what you
will don't hold your breath even as we
get close to the Finish Line because as
our correspondents have been saying
there's plenty there's plenty of
campaign rallies and events and
announcements expected today we'll
continue to bring you live coverage
throughout the day of this historic
event for now we're going to hand you
back to Doreen in Doha so I mean thank
you so much you'll keep us across all
the twists and turns thanks for the time
being